Bất biểu khai mặt khi nó, chuẩn thích bận trên mạnh, tại khi nó học này, vui bán thử gủ của gối sẽ xem sẽ bẩy nổi dùng quan trọc.
Trong đó, cho ý kiến về dự thảo kế hoạch giám sắp và để kương giám sát, việc thực hiện chính xác pháp lột về quan lý sử dụng ở chủ sở lần việc.
Sau khi thực hiện chủ chương sắp sẽ tổ chức bộ mái và đơn vì hành chính, nhấn mạnh đây là chuẩn thêm giám sát đầu tiên của gối khoảng 18,
chuẩn thích gối lưu ý, công tắc chuẩn bị và được tiến hành thật chạy, mạnh, và khoảng 20 ngày thử câu đầu tiên.
Chúng thầm dụng lãng vị, tựa cơm nhất là tình thầng vị quết số khu vốn của chúng hơn.
Chúng đến có hội cũng nêu gió, trên này vẫn đề khoảng lý sử dụng chủ sở lần việc sau khi thực hiện chủ chương sắp tổ chức bộ mái
và đơn vì hành chính đăng được dưới lộn sáo hội vô cùng gần tâm, thực tế vẫn còn tình trắng chủ sở đất đại tài sản công dưới sáo sắp sẽ chậm được dưới.
Cái thách trên hộ quả, người lãng vị một lực của nhà nước.
Cùng về đó, hối bán thử vụ của hội cũng xem sẽ mọc cao không tắc dừng nhận của khội tháng 5 năm hành hình thường trong ngày sau như thường lệ.
Sẽ tuo quan nghĩ quết về đánh giá sẽ bại chức lượng đối với vụ chuyên môn và sế dựng,
khoảng lý vị chỉ việc làm công trước vụ chuyên môn của hội đồng dân tộc.
Các vui bán của khội, chúng ta có hội nếu gió, bà đảm mộ mái tham yêu phải đổi mới chuyên nghiệp và nhiều khoảng hơn.
Về xế dựng vị chỉ việc làm phải thực chất, đúng người, đúng việc gió chính nghiệp gió sản phẩm.
Mới vị chỉ phải được xác định gió yêu cầu, giã vụ và khi quả đồ ra, khắc phục bị trạng đánh giá hình thức,
mấy năng, làm tốt phải được in nhận làm chưa tốt phải được tháng tháng chỉ ra để khắc phục xưa đổi.
Sẽ dựng đường đổi nữ công trước của hội chuyên nghiệp, chắc nghiệp, hấp ứng yêu cầu nhận vụ ngày khăn cao trong giai đẩm mới.
Chúng ta có hội cũng đề nghỉ, cầm tiếp tục phát vị tình thần học nhăn, gọi tập trung hiệu quả,
phí hòp điểm ra trong một ngày, những cần xem sẽ tử bệnh ở dùng quan trọng.
Mày đêm quan đến nhiều lĩnh vực khăn nhau.
Đó hỏi có sự tập trung chiếc tuổi cao của bán thử vụ cuối và khách hợp quan đêm quan.